hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tello sizer the solution for
precise detection and quantitative
measurement of telomere length
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by genomic vision to learn more
visit genomicvision.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker mark
lynch director of global commercial and
marketing at genomic vision
mark you may now begin your presentation
welcome to the genomic vision telo-sizer
webinar
my name is mark lynch i'm the director
of global commercial and marketing at
genomic vision
i'm here today to describe to you
telosiser which is a revolutionary
solution for the precise detection of
telomere condition
we hope you enjoy today's webinar
the agenda for today's session is split
up into three parts
the first is to provide an introduction
to molecular coming
the second part is to provide an
overview of telomere biology and
introduce to you telosiser which as
mentioned is our precise
method for the detection of telomere
length and the physical features of
telomeres
the last part is to announce to you
today artilocizer triathlon program
aimed at those in academia who wish to
try out the telo-sizer solutions
let's start with the introduction to
molecular combing
molecular combing is genomic vision's
proprietary method
for
stretching out aligning and immobilizing
dna
the principle of molecular combing is
that we
stretch align and immobilize dna
molecules on hydrophobic surfaces such
as our ingrained engraved cover slips
these engraved coverslips are
proprietary cover slips that contain
silene
the xylene enables dna molecules to bind
in a solution
and we then pull the dna
to create fibers of the dna in an
uncoiled fashion
this enables us to identify the
quantitative features of the dna such as
structural variants and replication
tracts
and it allows those
quantitative features to be analyzed
visually and at the molecular level in
parallel
an example of the fibers of dna on one
of our engraved coverslips is shown on
the right hand side of the slide where
we have yoyo one which is an
intercalating die
that shows the immobilization of dna to
the coverslip and the appropriate
staining
the example here is the type of density
that you would expect to see
and it also shows a uniformity
because with molecular combing and our
fiber based technologies we use constant
stretching factors to provide
visualization and quantification of
single molecule dna that can be used to
quantify the length and distances of
genomic features
therefore
our molecular coming application has
revolutionized molecular combing to
enable visualization and quantification
of structural features of dna for a
range of applications in single molecule
dna analysis
as mentioned we have our molecular
coming application this is shown on the
left hand side of the slide
and in this schematic where you can see
molecular combing
this here is what we've just described
on the previous slide
the key take home here is that any
sample from cells from blood or from
tissue can be used for molecular combing
provided that you have anything from
half a million cells onwards you'll be
able to
use this application for things like
replication analysis and telomere
analysis that we'll talk about later in
the presentation
and furthermore genomic vision provides
the appropriate dna extraction kit to
extract high molecular weight dna that
is enabling you to get ultra long fibers
to then comb and understand the
structural features of that dna
if that's not enough we also provide the
second critical part of our technology
which is our genomic morse code
the genomic morse code encompasses a
fluorescent and spatial molecular
analysis to be able to identify repeat
elements and
features such as deletion events
amplification events and inversion
events
the genomic morse code is a genomic
detection
strategy that's used to identify known
and undiscovered structural variants
to go back to the example here where we
start with the molecular cone dna
this molecular cone dna is stretched out
onto our engraved coverslips
and then we use a combination of
fluorescent probes of different colors
for example here in
blue red and green
and also in terms of different sizes
and spatial resolution so that a
specific
area can be identified
so for example in genomic morse code
we're able to look for different
repeatable elements
based on the number
of signals that we get
based on the distance between the
different probes and based on the length
and the color of the probes
as an example if we have a deletion
event shown here in gene one
it could be the case that we have a
genomic bars code that is in blue red
and green
we have the target deletion event that
we're interested in shown here in the
yellow and when that deletion event
takes place
there
blue and green remain constant but the
red actually becomes shorter
another example is in the amplification
step in the amplification step in this
case our motif is green red and blue
the amplification that is taking place
starts very small but then when the
amplification event occurs we get three
different regions
as a consequence our green and our blue
remain constant but the red elongates
and in similar situation with inversion
in gene three we again start with
blue
we then have our green and our red and
our blue again but in this inversion
event we swap around the red and the
green
and so as a result we're able to measure
that
essentially our genomic morse code is a
recognition of different motifs and the
code being based on the probe size and
color but also the distance in between
so
genomic morse code along with the
constant stretching factor in molecular
combing
enables an accurate and reproducible
measurement of the length of the probes
and the gaps that that occur in between
them
and it means that we can observe any
change in structural variation or dna
characteristics without performing any
pcr amplification
there are a few steps in our molecular
coming workflow
as mentioned the first part is the
collection of the cells blood and
tissues
once those cells blood and tissues are
collected genomic vision provides a kit
called the fiber prep kit that performs
a large molecular weight dna extraction
and once that large molecular weight dna
extraction occurs we then have our
genomic morse code probe design which
can be designed custom or we have
numerous off-the-shelf assays that can
be acquired
and those are labeled
we then use our fiber comb system which
is shown here at the bottom of the slide
and this fiber comb system is a small
bench top device that enables the
coating
and the stretching of uniform dna fibers
to perform the micro precise combing
we then immunostain that combed dna with
the probes and the genomic morse codes
that we described earlier
and as mentioned earlier that's why we
end up with these different motifs that
you can see in the schematic here of
different stretches of green and
straight different stretches of red
and we perform the immune imaging and
the analysis using either a fiber vision
or fiber vision s
instrumentation which performs the
scanning and also houses our fiber
studio platforms to be able to perform
the automated analysis
although today's webinar is all about
telosizer which is our newest
application measuring the precise length
of telomeres there are multiple
applications enabled by molecular coming
in this
slide you can see that we look at
various different types of applications
such as in genetic disease research such
as looking at repeat expansion and
contraction to associate diseases
such as looking at virus cellular
integration for example looking at the
uptake of hiv into cells
and also the detection of large
structural rearrangements
our molecular combing technology is also
used for cancer research where we look
at the accurate measurement of dna
replication kinetics including features
such as fork speed and fork symmetry
this therefore enables the
identification of rearrangements in
predisposing genes and genome assembly
and characterization
generally the genetic background and
cancer research markets are accommodated
by the academic markets
however we also have a more
bioproduction based part of our
technology which taps into genome
engineering and novel therapies and drug
development
the bottom left-hand side talks about
how molecular coming can be used for the
identification of unexpected
rearrangements again using that same
genetic bars code technology we
mentioned a few moments ago
and this enables the identification and
the assessment of how efficient a gene
editing method is
the application of molecular coming also
taps into drug development for the
identification of various features of
dna replication stress as well as drug
candidate validation
the common theme across all of these
applications are the high resolution
images that you can see on either side
of the dna double helix
our genomic morse code technology and
combed dna provides these high
resolution images of the structural
features of the genome
as such molecular coming helps to
characterize genomes across multiple
innovative applications
in genetics cancer research genome
engineering and in drug development
now because this seminar is based on
telo-sizer another critical application
or part of that is replication analysis
and their molecular coming
assays are commonly used for what we
call rca replication combing assays
so we can use our molecular coming
applications to understand the complete
characterization of any replication
events throughout the genome
and we use our genomic morse code and
our replication coming assay to identify
replication events
to understand the precise measurement of
replication speed
and we use automatic signal detection to
identify inter-origin distance of the
symmetry of the replication form
the image on the right-hand side with
the white arrows
shows examples of where we identify
different
lengths of replication events that are
taking place
an example shown where the pointer is
currently hovering over you can see that
we start with a particular fiber of dna
and we have one replication event
followed by another
we can use that same technology to
identify different replication events in
the same fiber
as such our molecular calming and
replication coming assay provides the
complete characterization of any
replication events through the entire
genome and is really becoming a primary
application in dna replication analysis
and while in this example we're
providing the identification of all the
replication events in the genome you can
get a lot more detailed in it and an
example of that here is in the accurate
classification of dna replication tracks
and so you can see here again using
urgent
using our genomic morse code
technology you can see the initiation
event taking place here in green
red blue red green
and you can see that that initiation
event is happening here and the second
initiation event with the longer red
signal is taking place here and the
third initiation event in green is
taking place here
and the same is true for the termination
events
so the replication combing assay enables
the detection of all of the different
combinations of the firings and timings
of the origins of replication and really
this assay helps to simplify
uncovering complex replication kinetics
that are not possible by other methods
now we're going to talk more about
telomere later on but there are two
other applications that we want to
introduce to you in this part of the
webinar today
the next application at a very high
level is an diagnostic application which
is ceivd
for the characterization of locus
modifications for screening of the d4 z4
repeat units
this is a solution that is a c e i v d
assay using molecular combing to
characterize the d4z for repeats of the
four q35 and 10q26 loci which is
responsible for the cause of a rare
disease called fshd
the molecular combing assay for the
study of fshd enables the identification
of the 4qa and the 10qa
regions of the genome
this is shown on the left-hand side of
the slide shown here where we have the
specific four qa and the specific 10 qa
being identified using our our coming
assay
we also identify 4qb and 10qb and again
using our genomic morse code technology
you're able to identify those specific
regions of that disease
and furthermore when there's a proximal
deletion in the 4qa in particular
deletion p13 e11 we're actually able to
see that deletion event taking place by
a gap in the genomic morse code
and so our assay actually doesn't just
provide the presence or absence of fshd
but it also characterizes
what is going on at the genetic level in
the subjects that are presented for fshd
screening
and this is a powerful tool to solve
complex rearrangements that are often
missed by technologies such as southern
blot
the last application that i'd like to
introduce to you today before we go on
to telo-seiser is actually our quality
chroming assay
we mentioned earlier on in the webinar
that if you're working in bioproduction
or drug discovery that we have various
assays under the branding of quality
combing assays that can be used for
screening of particular virus uptake or
so example is virus integration in cells
or that are used for therapeutic genome
editing both ex vivo and in vivo in
other words looking at that viral uptake
the same quality coming assay can also
be used as shown on the far left for
basic research looking at gene editing
for example and verifying the gene edits
that you have programmed have been
successful
and also used for biomanufacturing
engineering cells to make new biologics
in particular the bio manufacturing
example the molecular coming based
quality control in cell.line development
this really is a true bioproduction
based application
where the vector would be engineered and
a cell line would be engineered
and our molecular combing quality coming
assay can be used for the screening or
the clonal selection of that engineered
selling
once that selection takes place
single cell cloning can occur and the
same quality coming assay can be used
again to screen and make sure the clonal
selection occurs
and then as that cell line becomes
expanded and becomes banked the quality
combing assay can be used for the
genetic characterization and genetic
stability testing
so our molecular common quality control
ac can be used for screening vector
identity vector integrity copy number
co-integration and structural
rearrangements
we won't talk much about this in the
remainder of today's webinar but on our
lab routes page we've got pre-records of
our summer webinar program that talk in
detail about the quality comment assay
so the second part of today's webinar is
all about telomere biology and our new
telosci is our product
let's start by talking a little bit
about what telomeres are
so telomeres are a five prime to three
prime repeated motif of tta ggg at the
ends of human chromosomes that regulate
cellular plurative
capacity
the telomeres essentially protect the
chromosomes from deterioration and from
fusion
and so over time
telomeres are shortened after each cell
division until the cells become
senescent
and a shortening of telomeres are
generally associated with an increased
risk of multiple diseases
there are numerous telomere biology
disorders tbd's
and these tbds are caused by
non-physiological events or at the side
of the telomere
they really fall into two buckets the
first is premature shortening where
genome instability and loss of
fundamental functions occur
an example of that is in genetic
disorders and in aging
the second bucket is telomere extension
where genome instability causes a gain
of function for example in cancer
the great news is that no matter what
the tbd is the telo-sizer product from
genomic vision using molecular coming
can actually be used in oncology can be
used in age-related diseases and can be
used in genetic diseases
so oncology age-related disease and
genetic diseases and the idea as shown
in the literature is really that as
telomere land
changes over time
using telomere as a potential aging
biomarker is appropriate for telomere
therapies age-associated diseases and
cancer and there's a whole range of
diseases that are ongoing to try to
identify if there is a particular
biomarker that's associated with
telomere therapies or age associated
diseases
and so in the case of oncology telosizer
can be applied to
understand cancer stratification and
drug
deficiency an age associated disease
telosiser can be applied to diseases
associated with aging
and genetic diseases telosizer can be
applied for the investigation of
tallomar therapies
so telocizer is a critical application
that is used for tbd and an oncology
as mentioned earlier on in the
presentation the idea is that we use our
rep our
talo sizer application to study the tta
ggg repeat units that are found at the
ends of telomeres
our technology is particularly
applicable to that region because other
methods that rely on pcr would become
hindered by that constant repeat element
and because molecular combing in
principle does not
get impacted by those repeat elements it
means that we get a resolution that is
not always possible by other
applications such as next generation
sequencing real-time pcr pure fish or
flowfish and we'll show more of it what
we mean by that later on in the webinar
as mentioned earlier we have long
telomeres which show the preservation of
telomere capping shown on the left hand
side of the slide in the schematic
and that has problems based on dna
damage response cell cycle checkpoints
through atm and atr
and that can result in cell death
senescence and aging
we also have the flip side of that coin
which is the shortening of the telomeres
shown at the bottom of the schematic
where we have the end replication
problem of telomere sharpening
telomere shortening results in protein
loss and telomere uncapping
and in that case you get around about a
crisis that takes place particularly in
cancer which is really about 90 percent
in telomerase and 10 percent in alt
the key take home on this slide is that
in oncology telomere length
quantification is essential to uncover
the role of telomeres in genome
instability and cancer profiling
and in addition to the size of precisely
measuring telomere shrinking it expands
the utility by being able to enable a
direct quantification of genome
instability by detecting interstitial
telomere sequences and true telomere
sequences
and the image that you can see at the
bottom of this slide in particular here
is an example of the resolution that is
it that is provided using telosiser
the green is the dna fibers the telomere
is shown in red
and so in this example shown here where
the pointer is now this is showing a
long true telomere sequence
the second example here is showing a
short true telomere sequence
and the third example here is showing
the effects of an interstitial telomere
sequence
but please keep in mind we are doing
this whole genome these three examples
are just three examples of fiber in the
whole genome
to see the true power of this technology
you see that in the next slide we
actually use telos sizer for the precise
detection of telomere conditions
the best example here is shown where we
have one of our cover slips we mentioned
that earlier on the presentation an
engraved coverslip and that cover slip
if we take this very small section
within it this is the type of density
that you can see
inside that small region of the
coverslip
and so our fiber studio software
actually goes in an automatically
detects the red signal
the reason that it automatically detects
that red signal is because that is the
telomere that's the beauty of telocizer
every other method you would have to go
in and have primers and probes
specifically designed for that with our
telocizer application and the molecular
company technology we go in and we can
automatically detect all the telomeres
in that genome
and so it uses the um artificial
intelligence built in to our fiber smart
application which is dura launch later
this year
to actually measure the physical dna
fiber
and we can home in on each of these
regions to actually truly see the length
of the telomere whether it's a short
telomere a long telomere precisely
measure that telomere length and provide
a high resolution image of each of the
telomeres
so our technology really does provide
not only the individual lengths of each
telomere but it provides the
distribution per subject and provides an
unbiased result for telomere condition
and that's why telocizer is the precise
detection of telomere condition
here's an example of the type of images
that you would get telomere by telomere
long green single dna fiber and a red
telomere length and we put numerical
values on each of those so you see the
changes in telomere length along with
the distribution and along with this
high resolution image
a few moments ago we mentioned that the
fiber studio uses our fiber smart
application due to launch later on
this fiber smart application uses the
power of deep machine learning
to analyze engraved cover slips and in
this example they were derived from hela
cells
and we use that as a training model for
telo-sizer to determine the interstitial
telomere sequences and the true telomere
sequences
the image on the left hand side is one
of our cover slips the little blue line
that you can see
here is actually what our bioid group
uses to train the algorithms to identify
the long single molecules of dna within
the genome on the cover slip
the red that you can observe here is
actually the telomere
and so we use deep machine learning to
plot out what the telomere is and once
the telomere declines we identify the
red
and this has been found to occur with
sensitivity of 85
which as we build up more data will
improve to close to 100 percent
and the true value of the telo-sizer and
the analysis that we perform using hello
sizer and the fiber studio with the
inbuilt fiber smart technology is that
we've got a very short time in terms of
how we analyze all the telomeres within
the genome
and so if we actually go into details of
what the workflow for telo sizer
actually looks like you can see it here
sample collection takes a couple of days
once that sample is collected we then
perform single dna coming which takes
about seven minutes and that's followed
by a hybridization event which takes two
hours
once that hybridization is complete we
then take one to two hours to perform
the visualization and the analysis of
all genome of telomeres
now this workflow and timing is shown
here really just for your reference
because telosizer is actually a service
product
the samples in terms of the collected
samples are sent to genomic vision to
our services lab in paris in france and
genomic vision perform this end-to-end
workflow for you
and we provide you back with a report of
all the individual telomere lengths the
distribution per patient or per subject
and the high resolution images of those
telomeres
so you might be asking what are the
specifications
of telos sizer
the technical specifications of telos
telo-sizer which actually can be found
in our product flyer and our product
application on our website is really the
measurement of real physical telomeres
we detect both the true telomere
sequences and the interstitial telomere
sequences and we can measure our
genome-wide telomere shortening and
telomere extension
the resolution the actual telomere
length range that we can measure is from
1 kb up to 300 kb
and we provide as part of our service
results back to you the minimum the
maximum the mean size the standard
deviation and the distribution of lens
and our sensitivity is 87
using our fiber smart technology inside
fiber studio
as part of our validation of telo sizer
we of course looked across multiple
sample types
and we found that we were able to use a
whole range of different samples for
telo-sizer to get the telomere
distribution range and also the actual
length of individual telomeres
and so in this example taken from our
application note which is downloadable
from our website you can see that we
looked at u2s cells hela cells white
blood cells mouse liver tissue as well
as commercial dna
and we were able to get both the
distribution range using telos sizer and
the individual telomere length
and that's different actually from what
you get with other methods with other
methods you actually would get things
like the mean telomere length such as in
trf or the arbitrary arbitrary units
such as in q fish or relative telomere
lens such as in flowfish or real-time
pcr
whereas with telomere sorry the
telo-sizer genomic vision has been able
to provide you with the telomere length
distribution and the individual telomere
lens
so
in this example which is also found on
our application downloadable from our
website
we looked at multiple cancer cell types
to determine the precision of tylosizer
and you can see that when we look at
these different cell types healers
ii cf u2s and
ht1080 you can see that we actually get
much greater precision in telocizer with
telomere length distribution compared to
trf queuefish flowfish and real-time pcr
the last part is really to show you that
it's also applicable to translational
medicine based applications
and this here is an example of a family
carrying genetic history for breast
cancer reanalyzed by telosiser
subject one shown on the left hand side
has the non-pathological mutation and
normal telomere lens subject two carries
the defective gene which results in an
altered telomere length
and the beautiful thing when we look at
this is that based on the number of
region of interest or roi you can see
each of the individual telomere lengths
and your analysis software using the
fiber studio provides that distribution
so not only do you get the distribution
in this case for subject one of 8.3 kb
you also get the individual normalized
length intensities
the same is true in subject two
and when we look at subject two we also
identify the specific distribution of
telomeres and when we compare that to
southern blot while we get also a
distribution the thing that telo seizer
provides that southern blots does not is
the individual telomere lengths
and so compared to southern blood
analysis telosiser provides insight into
the distribution of telomere length by
per patient
and as such precisely identifies the
telomere length in each case
and therefore telosciser really is an
excellent service offered by genomic
vision for determining and understanding
telomere condition in cancer and in
other genetic diseases
the last part is just to show you
exactly what the telosizer product
services are all about
we actually have four services for
taylor sizer
this schematic is showing all of the
workflow for taylor sizer from sample
collection through the end result
depending on your labs configuration
depending on that budget we have
different services
the common service that is used is
actually our premium plus service which
offers end to end from dna extraction to
telomere length reporting and that's
called easy comb plus hello sizer
but we also have options for those that
don't want genomic vision to do the
analysis but just get the images back
and do your own analysis this is called
easy comb telosiser
and we also have solutions for those
that want to do the extraction and the
coming on site because there are clients
that have our fiber prep kits and also
the easy comb system and they can use
either easy scan helicizer where genomic
vision simply do the hybridization and
the image ask acquisition or easy scan
plus tool of sizer where we do that
hybridization image acquisition but we
also perform the visualization analysis
and the reporting
the take home here is that we've got a
variety of different services that can
be used to study telomeres
the last part of today's webinar is to
just talk to you about something that's
really exciting that we're very happy to
be launching and that is our toolsizer
triathlon
the tilo sizer triathlon is a new
program that is just launching today
the program launching today is open
until the 29th of november 2021
and it's us a genomic vision giving you
an opportunity if you work in academia
to could be considered for complementary
access to telocizer in other words if
you've got a project that really taps
into neurological diseases or
age-related conditions or cancer and you
would like to get some free access to
telo-sizer you can submit your project
today by going to artillo sizer landing
page on our home on our website and here
at the bottom of the slide is the url
for accessing that website
we'll also be providing you with the
flyer as a follow-up of attending
today's webinar to offer you access to
telo sizer and our tillocizer triathlon
program until
november 29th 2021
i will wrap up today's webinar we'd like
you to take home from today's webinar
that tulo sizer is a new service for the
analysis of telomere lens that can be
applied to various model organisms
it uses molecular combing and provides
an incredible resolution that is not
possible by other lab methodologies
and it uniquely detects and
distinguishes between true telomere
sequences and interstitial telomere
sequences to allow a clear understanding
of potential errors caused by dna damage
repair in cancer and other genetic
diseases
throughout the webinar we mentioned our
application note and our flyer these are
all available on our kilo sizer website
shown on the url at the bottom of this
slide
with that i'd like to thank you for
today's webinar and attending today's
webinar if you have any questions you
can contact us at sales
genomicvision.com and for now we'll
pause the webinar and take any questions
thank you mark for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the desired number of cells
required to use telocizer
yep thank you for that question
this the lowest input of cells really
would be about 50 000 cells um but we
would go up to around about half a
million cells and the reason for such a
range
is really dependent on the size of
telomere change
that one is trying to measure
so what you will have saw in the
presentation and on our application note
is that our resolution for telomere
length is between
1 kb and 300 kb
at the lower input of cells you'll not
see the small shifts in telomeres so
that's why we would say anything between
50 000
five hundred thousand cells and with
five hundred thousand cells you'll
actually be able to see shifts of
telomere length of actually between
point eight kb so that would be the
range between fifty thousand and five
hundred thousand cells
all right thank you
um next question
has telocizer been used with cancer
cells if so which cancer cells
specifically
yeah it has been used with cancer cells
and one of the studies that we
presented in today's webinar we actually
looked at the stratification of breast
cancer using telosizer that was one of
the plots that were in the
that was in the webinar that really
talks about um patient-derived cells so
we actually have used breast cancer
cells um to really study the carrier uh
mutation
for from braca and understand if
telomere could be an effective a
biomarker in that disease so we have
looked for example at breast cancer
cells as an example of that we've also
got studies that have ongoing with
things like pancreatic cancer cells as
well so this is this is something that
we've done yeah thank you
um next question
how can we use telosizer
yeah it's a good question um so as
mentioned in the presentation right now
uh taylor sizer is a service product
from genomic vision um that means that
essentially we um at genomic vision run
the workflow and we have a service
laboratory that's located in our
corporate headquarters in paris and in
france to basically receive the samples
so the best way to to use telosizer is
to get in touch with us at sales
genomicvision.com or actually you can
use our website we've got we've got a
nice landing page for tool sizer and
tell us about the project uh numbers of
samples um the type of service you
require because as mentioned in the
presentation we've got various different
types of service whether you want to
literally just send genomic vision the
cells and we do everything or for those
clients that already have some of our
bench top devices for combing dna um
those can be used to prepare the the
slides and send them to us so the best
way is really to get in touch but to
answer the question directly this is a
service so you send the sales to us or
you send the cover slips to us and we
process the samples so we take the the
labor of the workflow and we generate
the reports that contain all of the
individual telomere lengths that contain
the standard deviation the images and
all of the information you need to get
an understanding of the telomere
condition
all right thank you
um our next question what is the
turnaround time after we send genomic
vision samples
by which we get the data
yeah so our current turnaround time is
between four and six weeks we launched
telo sizer about two and a half weeks
ago and we've saw really great uh
interest from you know large
pharmaceutical
biotech companies that are actually
starting to run the services with
genomic vision so our kind of standard
turnaround times at the moment are
between four and six weeks naturally
when we look at the projects with our
clients when they contact us we look at
the number of samples we look at the
expected turnaround time if there are
any replicates and sometimes it can be
shorter than that sometimes it can be
longer than that but our average
turnaround time is between four and six
weeks
thank you
next question do you provide the actual
image analysis of telomeres and if so
how
yeah we do is the short answer um so
what you will have saw in the
presentation today is some examples of
the types of data that we at genomic
vision provide as part of the tulo sizer
services so for example we provide the
individual telomere lens we provide the
distribution of the telomeres within
that biological sample and we also
provide the the high resolution
individual telomere images
the how that we're able to do that
really relates back to
the fiber studio software and our very
smart algorithm called fiber smart which
uses artificial intelligence to
automatically detect the red signal the
red signal being the the telomere signal
and that would be measuring either long
telomeres or short telomeres or the
interstitial telomere sequences and so
the reason that we are able to provide
that
is because
of that algorithm because of that
artificial intelligence within the
software and frankly the way we provide
that to you is by providing access to
our fiber studio so it's all part of the
table size or service where you can go
in and get your images and look at those
images
thank you
next question
can telesizer analyze cell lines with
critically short telomeres
also
in alt cell lines where there is large
length heterogeneity will there be a
bias towards analysis of the longer
telomeres
i.e easier to detect
okay so i'll split that question up into
two so the first part i think was really
related to critically short telomeres so
in our in our specifications for table
sizer we we cite that we can do from one
kb up to 300 kb um we actually can do
shorter than 1kb we would have to talk
out the density of the coverslips that
we have to create to get shorter than
1kb but we have experience of going down
to 0.8 kb so the short answer is that we
can look at critically short telomeres
the second part of that question i
believe related to um alt cell lines
where there's a large length of
heterogeneity and is there any bias
towards the longer telomeres because
they're slightly easier to detect so
again we can go into a more technical
discussion on this it's largely related
to the density of the coverslips so we
actually recommend that we get a density
of around about 600 regions of interest
on those cover slips and with that
region um we don't actually observe any
of the bias but we would have to have a
conversation as to to how that is the
case the key part here really is that
with telosizer like our other
applications we don't um have any pcr
amplification taking place because the
molecular combing technology really
relies on hybridization so we don't get
that bias that you can sometimes get
when you perform pcr amplification in
applications such as next generation
sequencing or real-time pcr
thank you
next question
how about studying telomere replication
by combining
idu and cidu
and teleprobes
that's a brilliant question
um so so i think this question must come
from someone who clearly understands our
our value and the the critical parts of
tulocizer so this is something that's
absolutely uh on our radar um
we really um are trying to do this uh
this would assume you know the next
versions or the next partnerships that
we would uncover as as genomic vision
but yeah we we are looking at that we
don't have any product or application
not to talk to on that point right now
but it is something that is very
interesting especially in the dna and
the damage and repair setting
all right
um next question
how can we exclude that small telomeres
are not due to broken fibers
that's a good question also i mean maybe
i can take that back to the start of our
webinar today our presentation today
where we talk about how we do the um
how we comb the dna out onto the
engraved cover slips where we use this
so-called constant stretching factor and
so when we do that you know
essentially many people can stretch dna
but the way the proprietary way in which
genomic vision does that ensures that we
actually don't really get broken
fragments and so even if we did get
broken fragments the algorithm the the
artificial intelligence algorithm that's
built into fiber smart which is in fiber
studio for taylor sizer would be able to
call it but without going into massive
technical detail the way in which we
constantly stretch the dna onto the
engraved coverslips minimizes any broken
fragments that we would get
thank you
next question
can telomere analysis be combined with
replication fork analysis in the same
sample set
that's another very good question so
you know we've done quite a few of these
webinars actually and in the summer we
did one on replication um as well and
and we mentioned even in this webinar
actually that we've got a replication
combing assay
one can imagine that you know to really
truly understand the kind of
dna damage genome which i actually saw a
paper about a few months ago one has to
look not just at the replication
dynamics and kinetics one has to also
look at the impact of that on the
telomere and so while again to go back
to the earlier question where someone
was asking about the idu and combining
teleprobes
one can imagine that we want to be able
to look at as many factors as we can to
really characterize what is going on in
damaging the genome telomere and
replication we're just not there yet but
it's a very good question and certainly
the molecular combing technology can be
used for that
thank you
you know it looks like we have time for
one more question
can your genomic morse code system
coupled to the rca be used to study dna
replication kinetics at specific genomic
loci
well so this is something that's very
interesting so it goes back to using our
you know the what we call gmc genomic
mars code it goes back to being able to
rather than looking at that at the whole
genome level looking at that in a
targeted level and the answer is yes um
we've got some clients who actually
already do that on the on the
replication part
and then one can imagine if you're
looking at it in terms of telomere do we
want to get quite specific on the
chromosome level for example for the
telomeres and again that's something
that we do want to look at so the short
answer to the question is cat is yes it
can be coupled to um rca as a specific
loci um the longer part is we would have
to have a technical discussion as to how
we would do that as part of our genomic
morse code assay design
well thank you
and thank you again mark for your time
today in your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor genomic vision for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye